Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome back to Resident Evil 7. Now we got a croc situation in that creek and we got
To take care of it, so don't worry Zoe
I'm gonna go get a cure somehow and try not to think about how I ruined everything. Where'd that croc go? Hey!
Hey, where are you going? You got scared of hitty and fisty? I know how it be. Hello? *giggling* punch oh ho ho ho ho
A stealth kill you say, what are you doing here? Stealthy!
Eugh! The silent-est
Yeah why do they have a croc head?
Well that don't make any sense at all. How this camp be here long enough to get a croc- ooh
Hey, do you want some of hitty and fisty? I even - well I g - I guess I could have snuck up on you. It didn't seem to matter
Hoooooooaaaaaaaa - booski!
*Laughs* Ah!
Oh, It's a fast one. Bwap. Oh!
Jesum. Ah! Jesus.
Holy shit, those guys - those guys don't ta - I gotta get kicky - kicky and swifty involved. My god
Alright, well, time to come in low I guess. Alright let's see what I can do about that. I'm not-
I'm not 100% sure I'm happy with how that went down
God you know, I don't know if I'm not picking up a gun by choice
Or if it's just the only way he knows how to fight. Eugh. Alright. Let's try to be a little more...
Stealthy about all this
Hello?
Er - hello? Oh there you are.
Okay, and there you go. You ain't gonna know
Noooh, DIDN'T SEE A THING, DIDN'T SEE A THING
This big giant man is the stealthiest around. It's all that football I played
Definitely got my stealth and skills up. What is this? Grub?
(Chuckling) Why were they-? Why were they looking at grub?
Through a microscope what kind of scientist is like: hmmm? This grub would mix well with chem fluid for some reason
Alright...
Oh, hey buddy!
(laughing)
Oh g - oh god!
Euh. You know I don't know if those things feel pain, but actually now, I'm pretty sure they do
Alright, well. That was fun, glad I did that, but also, why?
Ooh! (Gasp!)
A stabby stick!
A throw-
(wheezing laugh)
Hi-ya! (More wheezing laugh)
Ho-holy shit!
Wow
It's just like I used to throw the football back in my footing days. Alright then. Wham, bam, bu-bu-bu bu boom!
o-ho-okay
Jeezums!
I love this so much, and I'm gonna be permanently stuck in an accent from now on. Oh boy
I got two tiny punching Peters. Whatever I called them. Alright jeez this is so funny
I love this so much
Oh, man
You guys don't understand. The bold choice of turning Resident Evil into a punching game. Like I can't believe it
But also I'm so happy they did
Alright, orders are as follows, effective immediately: the mutamycete is on the loose in the swamp
And it'll keep mutating as it encounters new organisms
We can't allow the stock and medicine compounds to be exposed - if they suffer a mutation
They'll be useless. Transfer the whole anti-infective synthesizing station over to the paddle boat
Ah yes! The paddle boat - the most defensive of all military compounds
Yeah, no joke about that one there Pappy slim. So, uh, any ancient coins around here? Alright anyway
Imma keep going. Ah, my lamp. Oh no
Cuz tha - woah!
Uh oh, well, hi. You wanna go?
You best stay back now. In case you wanna a bit of hitty and swifty. Hitty and lefty? Alright come on, come on
Ha!
Bom miss me. Ah!
Follow-up? Who'd have thought?
Huuuuuuuuuu!
Uh-oh!
Ah I forgot he had a f - wha! No!
Oh you tired? Oh you tired? Well I ain't!
Okay, miss me!
*Laughs*
You suck! Whap, whap whap whap whap!
And, no. Wow - wow nice hey maker. (?) Whoa
Ho ho ho!
Caught ya! I call that a counter - oh, a kick? Really? Imma punch right in your ass. That's what you deserve.
Oh yeah - oh, that's what I call a combo
oh-ho-ho oh-ho
Oh no, you ain't! My fist made sure of that! Ah you made of grub? Ooh
You look like.. ooh! Grub, grub! grub!! Oh, there's grub. Okay fine then
Then I'll be on my way, I suppose
Alright. Enough grubbing up a storm here
grub-a-dub-dub
*Gasp* GRUB!
(Laughing) Crawfish?
What is a crawfish doing on a rock this far from the crick? Alright fine then
Alright I'll call him a Craw-dead
Is there a difference between Craw-dead and crawfish? As a kid -
Oh hey, wow!
Hey!
Yeah, that ain't gonna happen. Or get back up I don't care. Fine by me
Ow!
Whoa, ow!
Woh-oh!
Euh!
Kick you in your ass, I know your weak spot. Fisty's going to town on that ass. Uh-oh
Ow!
Whoa, I fell! Oh let me put some grub juice on me. *Splurt*
Well you want some? Oh, I'll come back. I'll come - I'll come back up punch your ankles buddy. Oh really?
Oh, he d - yeah, you better run I fell down this small alcove
And thusly you can't fight me no mo'. Alright fine then *laughs*
Alright sure ok - grub
Mm! Yum. Yum yum -  ooh
Hey!
Convenient spears! *laughs*
Oh jeez - wait I gotta go in this building over here
Oh, this is the best. The best thing ever. Craw-dead! Alright sure, sure why not
Alright, hello? Ah
There's still - oh! A tiny punching Peterson, man
They sure are giving me a ton of these. Save points here
So exactly like is the most - most intrepid adventure going between these that I've ever seen
But you know I'll - I'll take what I can get. Euh it's so fun. Locked from the other side
Okay. So I guess I guess I can't just punch that gator
Now can I? You want to get speared? Oh you want to get speared?
Hah hah, ho-ho!
Ho whoa. Wow. Wow. Woah where are you going? Wait wait? It's not that deep. W - it's not that deep!
Uh-oh!
*Insert sounds here*
*Laughs*
I mean I feel terrible for that - my gator! Uh-oh! Punch you gator
Ah! Aaaaaaaay!
What? What?!
Ow, well, alright then
Fair, fair, fair, I suppose, I suppose that's fair, fair, alright, okay, alright. Hi Zoe
How you doin'?
Euh. Alright. Well, take twoooooooooo. So rule number one: don't punch the gators
*Laughs*
Rule number three (I think you skipped rule number two Mark) - oh, that one. Ohhhhhhhhhh that was always there
Blap!
Oh another one. Another spear. Perfect. I'm glad these are just here lying in the water. Perfect for me
Okay, oh
Ha-ha! Coo - If I'd have missed that I would've been eternally boned huh. Alright see ya
Uh-oh
Well - oooooooooooooh
Wowie zowie I'm out of spears. Okay
I'm just gonna hold - that's, that's no good that's no good. Uh-oh uh-oh uh-ohhhhhhh
How - errrrrrr
Oh *laughs*
Okay. Alright that seems better. Yeah, I'll go up this way instead of going to certain
Death, which is usually what I like to do in these games they - ooh
Hey - aww come on! Did the light give me away?
Alright fine then - bam!
B - lap bap bap bap!
W - whap, w - whap, wh - whap, whop whop whop, whap, whoa I don't remember what the actual combos are so -
Oh! What's that - what's that? Ho, couldn't hear you can you speak up -  uh-oh
Oh yeah, oh - oh *laughs*
God I feel so strong. This is not usually normal li - life. I do not usually feel this strong - hey!
Hooooooooow did you get up here gator? On my pier? I'm assuming that all this territory is mine and not anybody else's
Alright well
You er, you have a nice nap now gator. No no sorry
I can't be seduced like that. Jeez I wonder what the - I wonder what the infection is gonna do to those when they fully infect them
Probably not too fun, if I had to guess. Alright gator. Good thing I got this amazingly advanced spear
Shoot! Oh no! Right in your butthole
Ohhh so sorr - ooh
Right in your - b - ear, I guess. Alright see ya. See ya. See ya!
Well. Oh this must be the back door to that other shed - you think I'd be - with my punching skills
I coulda just bashed my way through that, but nooo
Alright, well there we are. Alright let's see. Okay another - no not there, not there. Hup! Okay
*Laughs*
Sorry I just - I'm tickled to death by this game. It's not usually you know this - Resident Evil 7
It was a big surprise when it came down to it being a
Like a fun game number one, but number two, the bigger surprise was that it had this
Interesting like, tongue-in-cheek nature to it. That was - oops sorry, er
Oh jeez, oh jeez
It had this like tongue-in-cheek nature to it that just made it a - a - a really like genuine experience
Like it was a game especially in the DLC and stuff
It was a game that took itself as a game more than it took itself as like a super serious story
Which is why it leads to like incredulous moments where it's like, okay alright
That's a little - that's a little silly billy there, but you know it's - it's just really fun, and - and I think that's - that's emphasized
It's both fun and scary
Like it can do all of it, and - and it's kind of a trend that's happening in - in like modern media today
There's a lot more like horror movies and horror genre stuff that has like a little bit of qu - humor to it
and I think like, the campiness of old style like er, of er
Er of like the old horror movies like, it was always campy and it was always a little tongue-in-cheek
because it was so ridiculous, and we got away from that a little bit, I'm
Er I - I - like I - I'm not a hundred percent sure there's plenty of movies that took them so seriously, but that little bit of like
Sardonic humor, you know the - the - the little touch of sarcasm throughout the entirety of it
That's - that's what I really liked about some of these horror things
And I think this game actually puts that forward in a really good way, and I don't know. I just love it because - ooh
Oh, woah! Hey, what the hell?
How am I gonna punch your head with spikes in it? This is bullshit alright well. You're new
Okay - whoa, hey, sent you spiraling. Can I stop you? Or are you just dead? Okay he's dead. Alright well. That was weird
Yeah
But it's - it's just the little evolutions that lead it down a road where it's semi-serious - centipede! Semi-serious
And yet so lovable. Like Joe Baker sure yeah
Joe Baker doesn't exist. He was contrived after the thought and this is just uh this is just like a - ooh
This is just an environmental thing that allows people to have a little bit more fun - ooh
With what they're doing. And that's good, because sometimes that's needed
Which way you going? Okay?
Alright
Uh-oh!
Hello? Oh you're twitchy huh? Oh you're gonna be twitchier now!
Hi-ya!
Okay, anyway got it going. Wait why did they put this on the paddleboat? Like putting it on the pa - I'm assuming
I'm on the paddle boat right now
*Laughs* Why was there a grub in the box?
*More laugh* A tree branch!
I've got a tree branch - a thick strong tree branch. Can't be used as is. *More laugh* Of course. Of course you can't
*Even more laugh* Why would it be -
*I think he might die of laughter soon D:*
A stake bomb!
*D:*
*D:* I just gotta put this -
*DDD:* I just gotta put this chem fluid
On this tree
And it turns into a bomb? *Ok I think he's toning down on the laughter now*
Oh boy man if I'm putting that on grubs and they turn into medicine
And I put it on a branch and it turns into a bomb. Oh, that's so fun
Press left click to stick it on the ground press R to detonate - that makes no sense
How did I make this with chem fluid? *D:*
That makes no sense - oh hey you wanna go toe to toe buddy? Alright alright alright alri - let's go. Alright let's go let's go
Uh-oh. Wow, wow, he is not tough. You'd think I'd hurt my hands on him, but noo. Oh hello, scrap-metal. I'll take that
Alright what else we got? Oh, is that just the other way that I could have crawled through? Let me see if there's a - oooooh
Well, that's probably the cure station. Let me see if there's a grub in this thing or maybe a tree branch - uh-oh
Well, I don't like that guy. He seems to - wait hang on, wait wait, wait
Hang on, euh, put it on the grill. Okay. Alright
You coming over here?
Come on. Oh, okay, alright wait, hang on, wait, wait wait
I got this
Ok how do I - *laughs* wait wait wait ever - wait everybody, wait
Hold on - *more laugh* why isn't it beep - what in the -
Was it the tree branch or the chemical that causes it to beep? Alright he - he's getting closer guys. He's getting closer
He's getting closer. I somehow got a remote for this
*Noises* Boink!
*Laughs D:*
Tiny punching Peter, oh boy, I saved you from that box shard falling on you. Oh look
It's a free throwing spear. This is the greatest thing I've ever seen in my life
You know ordinarily you know in some games
They could do these sort of things and I'd just be like ah this is ridiculous
But this is ridiculous in such a good way in such a honestly and truly good way
It's so good. Oh man hang on
I got to read up on my punching skills again because I want to just make sure that I got it. Right left left left
Okay, left right right right, right left left left, okay
Those are the two combos. Got it. And I'm sure there's more combos that I could do
But I just don't know them right now. Alright who's there?
Huh?
Low guy or - or fisticuffs man. What are we gonna do about this?
Oh
Ah
Okay well
Well I co - ooh. I can sneak up on you
HIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIII-YAAAAAAAAAAAAA!
Alright
Hey, you're not gonna see me. What are you even doing?
He's - he's j - he's just sick on the ground. He's like ah I c - I can't find my contacts, and I just rip his freaking head off
Cuz I'm an asshole like that
Alright, what do we got?
Yeah, everything seems marginally less scary when I know that I can just punch things to death. I'm gonna eat some critters, so
*Laughs*
Not bad. Slimy yet satisfying
Ha ha ha ha
Okay, alright, where are we going now? Oh boy I love this. I love this - oh is there a grub in this box
Bonk! Tree branch *laughs*
The tree branch was bigger than the box
*More laugh* And who would put a branch in a box?
Oh, this is the funniest shit I've ever seen in my life, okay, I could go down here
Let me explore around first
Oh wait no something tells me this is gonna be the secret sneaky way
Which is the way that I like to go, and the way that I'm definitely gonna be going. So there we go
What do we got - ooh! Whoa!
Whoa!
Whoa! Champion effigy
What?
Oh shit a creepy doll used for black ma -
*Laughs* - gic
Is that what they are for? Black magic? Champion effigy. Alright, I got - I got way more punching power. Alright *laughs*
Oh this is so - I hope there are minigames associated with this game mode. There better be like an unlimited mode after I get done - whoa, hello
Uh, hi, well, hang on
Okay
Hang on, hang on
Miss me
Hup! Hup!
Hooooo!
Yooooooo!
Are you dead? You dead? You're twitching, like he ain't dead
Eugh god the way your teeth move. Well that ain't natural. Alright need another grub
*Laughs*
Haha, what a freakin' badass!
What a -  what a
What an amazing human being. What an incredible person. And how does that heal him? I wonder I wonder. I wonder with thunder
*Laughs* How?
How, how does that work? I don't know and I don't care. Oh, that's a spear. Okay well
Alright then how did it get there? Who threw it? It was jutting that way! I don't know I don't understand
I don't know anything, but I am amazed. I am just amazed - can I climb up here? Can I not climb up here?
Oh, yeah, okay, alright
Okay alright, gotta go to the stairs. Yeah I can't climb up the two feet that it would require to be able to do that
Yeah, definitely not. Okay alright. Well then, let's go in here then, and have a great time *laughs*
Alright. Now we're gonna get the cure and hopefully something's gonna arise out of this
Auto synthesizer. Yeah, this is definitely the safest place for this, surrounded by all these -
No, not everything's solved by punching, Joe! Joe!
*Laughs for a really long time D:*
This is really - uh, no game has made me laugh more than this game
*More laugh for good measure*
Apparently oh bo - oh hey you wanna get punched? *laughs*
Oh jeez
*Laughs even more D:*
Wow okay he just threw me? Oh jeez *laughs*
Alright guess it's time to go toe-to-toe with Joe! Alright come on man you want some of this?
*Mark's warcry + laugh*
Ow!
Oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh
Ow! Holy crap! Whoa!
Okay, alright. You wanna go? I got all my skill in here. Yeah, that's right. Oh, yeah
Oh, yeah, yeah, you ain't gonna do n - whoa
Come on. Whoa
Come on
Yeah, yeah. Hang on, I gotta restore some health. Gotta slap some goop juice on me don't mind me
Imma see what's in - what's in this. Ooh! Hey that's nice. Alright. Okay Alright
Hang on
Give it to me? What am I giving to you? What the hell? Hey I was guarding - uh-oh
Wh - ow!
You didn't say that we could use our heads
I've never used my head for anything
Anything - day in my life! Whoa hey, alright hang on
Just seeing a - oh god! I got a branch! I got a branch! Hang on, I got a branch. Ah shit. Hang on, I got a branch
Oh shit, I'm out of chem fluid. What do I got? Whoa!
Whoa what is that? What was that?
What are you trying to do there? Come on, come on, come on! Come on!
Ohhhhhhhhhhhh! Miss me
Ow! Frick! Alright, hang on.
Uh-huh, uh-huh, uh-huh, uh-huh, uh-huh, here we go here we go here we go here we go!
Oh shit! *Laughs* Oh shit! Oh shit! Oh shit!
Wha - what did that do? *Laughs* I don't r -
I don't frickin' wrestling move
Ow! Backhand. Come on now
Uh-oh! No no no no no no
Ow. Hang on, I'm blocking
Uh-oh!
Ow I blocked
Come on. There we go get some - hey, I gotta get some grub juice on me. I'm gonna think about this one
Yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah, yeah, yeah! Got you on the ropes now!
Oh yeah! Ow ow ow ow!
Whoa miss me baby - miss me baby
Uh-oh! Ahhhh running! Euuuuuh!
Ow!
Ah!
Okay, okay, okay
Whoa whoa whoa!
Ow! Ow!
Yeah yeah yeah, yeah
Oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah the finisher. The finisher, baby. I call this one the f - I don't know what I'm doing. Why am I grabbing your *incoherent* now
Ho! Ohhhhhhhh shit!
Whoa
Euh man
Who knew that these uh
Who knew that these horrible evolutions of fungus and virus weren't the peak pinnacle of evolution?
Cuz wow
Joe, man, Joe
Joe Joe Joe
Wow *laughs*
I am impressed. Time to celebrate with a grub. Come on Joe. You know you wanna
Ah, oh - OOOAAAAAAA!
*Laughs* Joe! Nooooooo!
*More laugh* No, Joe, Joe, no
Joe!
Joe baby Joe, Joe no no oh. Call you
No no Joe Joe. Oh boy. Wow. Alright well anyway got what I came for I guess
*Laughs* Holy crap
Ah good, chem fluid I can make that bomb I wanted to make *laughs*
Perfect. Got a bomb, which is exactly what I needed. Alright shootilydoodilydoo
Making my way back to Zoe now I guess
Euh is anything gonna actually stand in my way? Oh! *Laughs*
Well that was convenient! Alright well *laughs* here we go then
I swear I'm n - I'm a giggly bitch, but you know this is - this is goddamn funny. This is - this is so funny
Oh what's gonna stop me? Uh-oh. Oh come on? Hey! What? Well that's not good!
Oh you want to go for round three huh? Round three huh? Oh I'll get you through round three. Okay anyway
That's all the time we got for this episode, but goddamn
This is the funniest thing I've ever seen so thank you everybody so much for watching
Let me know what you thought down in the comments below
And as always, I will see you in the next video!
BYE BYE! :D